when you're starting off in pillars of
eternity Mary Kish you got to create a
character first thing you do lots of
decisions to make there and we're gonna
break some of them down so that you guys
have an idea of what awaits you as you
get started in pillars of eternity so
step one well the first step is to pick
a sex male/female that's it there's no
other options and it doesn't really have
any benefit on it you know in terms of
tangible in-game anything go with your
gut is your gut a dude or a lady second
step is to select race and sub race this
is when it actually starts changing the
kind of character that you want to make
and there are benefits and consequences
to the person you choose right so you're
gonna get bonuses to different
attributes and these six attributes are
stuff they're gonna be familiar to
anyone who's played a game like this
before my Constitution dexterity
perception intellect resolve they're all
sort of familiar and you can read up
about them there's like a lot of text in
this game so if you're ever curious
about it
mousing over it is a good way to find
out a little more so a lot of these give
benefits you know the al Maleh
they get double might points elf gets
dexterity and perception but you said
there's also consequences because some
will subtract right so the Orlan group
you get resolved and you get two
perceptions but you lose might so
orleans would be kind of a weaker thing
whereas and also dorbz they get two
might and they get constitution but they
lose a dexterity so there's always a
give-and-take with these characters and
later on you're gonna get to get a bunch
of points to pour into these attributes
so you could mitigate any negatives you
have or lean into any strengths but this
race is really where you start choosing
what kind of direction you want to go
what kind of archetype do you want to
fill in this fantasy world there's also
a sub race choice and these aren't
attributes or skills or anything in
particular they're just kind of little
bonuses so when I chose between two
types of al Maleh one had a benefit to
say stun or prone attacks and they would
stand their ground a lot more strongly
when with God like they had four
different options and you do that
because your ego is literally out of
control I just couldn't resist
of course of course this is a discussion
for another time but there's four
options for God like if it could be kind
of like a dark death like godlike or you
could do moon fire moon was interesting
because if endurance goes down 75 50 or
25% I got my entire group an endurance
bonus which is pretty nice but they each
have different ones I remember the first
time I played I went with elf and the
different types of elf give you other
bonuses where whether it be having
better aim or kind of being immune to a
particular kind of poison or something
so you're already charting the course
for your character and the next step is
to choose your class again you're gonna
see a lot of familiar archetypes here
barbarian fighter pallid and Ranger
priest rogue there's gonna be a couple
different ones that maybe you know are a
little bit deeper cuts a cypher or a
chanter but here instead of seeing
attributes change that you're seeing
skills and these are it's they kind of
function like attributes you're gonna
get checks against them throughout the
game but they're different class of kind
of determining characteristics stealth
athletics lore mechanics and survival
when it came to class I went with a
chancer which gave me a few skills gave
me two in lore and one in mechanics but
actually didn't see a huge benefit of
that early on game so you might find
that your attributes have more of a
broad range they come in a little bit
more handy at first than your skills
might and we saw that immediately when
you start the game you're you're already
put into some situations where your
particular class will affect how it
plays out well didn't you get a lore
check early on because there's a
situation where like some bandits have
raided your camp hella dudes are dead
but they've got this one guy captive and
basically it's the first real check
against your attributes and skills and
then a couple ways you can go cuz you
obviously don't want him to get stabbed
maybe you try to avoid a fight maybe you
trotted like sweet-talk him like how did
that go for you
right so when I did it with my chanter I
had enough intelligence to talk him out
of it and it distracted him enough where
I could get my guy free and saved his
life yeah and there's other ways it can
play out I had a strong athletic skill
cuz I chose the Barbarian class so I
just bum-rush the dude
and before they knew what was happening
I was clobbering them and my dude was
free so even right from the get-go
you're seeing decisions that you make
coming back around later on so later on
there's another instance with heyo Don
where he's grabbed by an enemy and you
need to find a way to set him free I
think I had three options I could I
could try to throw something out of my
weapon you could just grab a rock or you
could say you figure it out hey Don you
got this buddy you give him moral
support see how it plays out my first
playthru with an elf I had enough
dexterity where I could just grab a rock
and roll out of his dome and I did and
he escaped and there was just no
problems whatsoever whereas I was not
that dexterous as a barbarian had to
chuck my sword totally had the same
effect it worked except when I got into
the cave
no sword on my second playthrough when I
played the chanter I didn't have enough
dexterity and I didn't have I didn't
really want to throw my weapon I leave
my weapon in this thing I just said you
got this buddy and he died he got killed
straight up died he died my third player
for hey Oh Don there gonna be some
situations in which there's only one
attribute being checked like that Rock
throw situation was only a dexterity
option but then earlier this sort of
talking it out with the guys who had him
hostage there were multiple routes to
take so you know any way you specialized
you're gonna be you know leaving some
things behind and I think that the game
is really encouraging you to specialize
when you're doing the distribution of
your attribute points
it says highly recommended for your
class it's really trying to get you to
specialize and lean into it which makes
sense because that's how a lot of these
party based RPGs work the idea is you
get strong at some things and then you
supplement your weaknesses with strong
party members and that's also shown
later on in a week looking wall that's
happening I was - I wasn't strong enough
I couldn't push it over my party member
was I didn't need to be strong that's
fine
teamwork making the dream work there are
a few other character creation
stages that affect your attributes and
skills you get to choose your culture
what region did you come from as well as
your own personal background sort of
what's your story whether or not you're
rich or you were a slave or you're just
like a loner
yeah those allow you to specialize a
little bit more and then of course you
wrap it up by just customizing your
whole appearance and then realizing that
oh there's only three character
portraits and you don't look like that
one damn it there were not enough
portraits you pick a voice after that
there's no benefits to any of this stuff
and then you get to name your character
which if anything just gives you the
sweet benefit of being named Doug I mean
I think of all the high fantasy
adventurers that time has brought into
our lives Doug is truly one of the more
majestic names Doug the chanter agrees
Doug the chanter Wow that's a terrible
combo so there are some of our stories
from character creation in pillars of
eternity and the consequences it has
right out of the gate share some of
yours in the comments below and happy
adventuring
well there we were within the cave the
spiders came to take us to our grave but
then we found the millenarian alba the
wandering one why